Basically, it was like,
get out of your heads,
start doing things and make it happen
and it feels great.
Amy Wyron Robinson,
how are you?
Doing great, thanks.
How's it going?
Wonderful.
Thank you so much
for being on my show.
I'm very excited to talk to you
about mobility, transportation.
You were the VP Global at Gett taxi,
Israeli-based Unicorn
that is a hugely popular
ride sharing service.
But before that,
you were also very involved
with Waze and Moovit.
Now, most recently,
the chief operations officer of Nemodata.
But your journey is a little bit weird.
It wasn't obvious
that you're going to end up
being the CEO of a growing startup
or the VP at a unicorn.
You actually started back
in Duke in politics.
So, talk to me a little bit about that.
And I'd love to tie in,
your fun fact of being,
being a certified yoga instructor.
Yes.
So, lots of different elements
and all going together.
So, first of all,
thank you for having me.
It's really a pleasure to be here
and share a little bit about my journey.
So, you're right.
I started back
studying politics and economics
back at Duke many, many years ago.
And I thought
that I wanted to be a diplomat.
That was my kind of first career.
I grew up in Washington, DC.
And then at some point I realized
that being a diplomat
meant working for the government,
which wasn't suited so well
to my personality.
And I decide to look for other
opportunities or ways to go abroad,
and kind of reached out
to some people at Duke,
ended up working in Latin America
for about four years.
How did you get to Latin America?
It's not the most obvious path
from Israel to Duke to Latin America.
Yeah.
So, I went there
initially to study abroad.
I had the choice between
Spain or Bolivia,
and I chose Bolivia,
kind of the less traveled path.
And after spending some time there,
I got connected with some alumni
from my university
just to ask them,
I was really curious,
-what are you doing here?
-how are you doing it?
And so, from those conversations,
it ended up turning into a role for me.
And it grew from there.
So, after a couple of years,
I decided that I wanted to continue
growing in my career,
and do my MBA.
But there was some really,
there was a dissonance between
going from Latin America
back to the US to do an MBA there.
So, enter Israel.
During that time
I visited Israel for the first time.
And startup nation,
everything's exciting
that's going on here.
So, I decided to come to Israel
to do my MBA
10 years ago.
And you could say the rest is history.
The rest is history.
Yeah.
So, that history
is still very, very long
because you've been
an MBA consultant for Waze,
and then you worked for Moovit
and Gett Taxi,
Why Mobility?
What is it about mobility
that really got you excited?
So, during my MBA,
we had a project where we
reached out to an Israeli startup
and basically had to pitch ourselves
to do a project during our studies.
So, my teammates and I
pitched ourselves to Waze.
We wrote an email to Uri Levine.
"Hi Uri,
we would love to work
for you, with you on any project
that you need."
And to our delight,
he replied, "Sure."
As simple as that.
Just kind of,
shooting for what you want
and sometimes you surprise yourself.
So anyway, Uri became an amazing mentor.
And I think it's really through him,
that first of all,
that I fell in love with startups
and decided to stay in Israel,
not only do my MBA here.
And also he taught me the difference
between managing and building.
And when you go to your MBA,
a lot of it is about managing.
How do you manage you pin
how you manage, how you control,
versus building something new.
Yeah, so I think in startups,
especially in the world,
again, you ask about mobility,
-why do I like it?
-why am I into it?
Because it's changing.
Because it's growing.
It's not managing
something that exists,
it's building something
that you are imagining for the future.
And taking all of the micro steps now
to make this macro vision a reality,
this is something I think
that he really encouraged us to do.
He basically was like,
get out of your heads,
start doing things,
and make it happen.
And it feels great.
So, yeah.
So, this is how I got into startups,
into mobility and through Uri
I met the founders Moovit.
So, even within mobility
what's been your sweet spot?
What has been the area
that you've been really focusing on?
So, I would say
there is kind of two aspects
to what really gets me excited.
One is, like you mentioned,
building from scratch to scale.
So, having this kind of
zoom in, zoom out approach,
what's the macro vision,
what's our North Star,
where are we aiming for,
and then kind of reverse engineering
all of the little steps
that need to be executed on
to get there.
So, it's not enough to have
only the vision,
you have to be able to execute on it
and you have to be able
to engage people around it.
So, I'd say it's kind of building
from scratch to scale
is something that,
if I think of the moments
that were most exciting or most,
when I was in my state of flow,
it's these moments.
And I think the other piece of it
is partnerships.
So, a lot of my career
has focused on
partnering with others
to create value,
both within the organization,
other organizations.
And kind of trying to figure out
how we can get there together
because we're not going
to get there alone.
Right.
But still, it comes to me that,
the things that you were mentioning,
the zoom in, zoom out scale partnerships,
that is something
that is pretty common
to across the board
when you're looking at the tech sector.
No matter really what industry you're in,
you're going to be dependent on,
and reliant on the partnerships,
and on great scale and growth
on any size of businesses.
So, still, why mobility?
Why helping people get
from point A to point B?
Because I can imagine
you now going to Slack
or Twitter or Google and saying,
we can do the same thing there.
I think there's something
really special about mobility.
I love it, obviously.
There's something about the fact
that it affects your daily life.
Someone mentioned that a good app
should be like a toothbrush,
you use it twice a day.
And so, I think mobility is something
that really affects our lives
and affects the quality of our lives.
When it comes to your commute,
how much time you're spending,
getting where you're going.
These days, these covid days,
it's a bit different,
-how is it changing,
-how is it evolving.
But I think that we're seeing
these dramatic dramatic shifts
in something that affects
people's daily lives
in a really significant way.
I mean, hours and hours of every day
are spent moving around.
And so, I really get excited
about things that can really impact.
So, having seen a lot of the different
innovations that have been going on
over the past few years in the space,
where are we heading?
Because it feels to me
as more of a bystander that
we have these great tech companies
that are developing
these great technologies
to link drivers and riders,
even link riders and riders.
But we've reached some milestone where,
it's easy for me to get a taxi
no matter what,
but I haven't seen really
major advancements
in the past two, three years.
Are there big advancements
to look forward to in the mobility space?
Sure.
So, I think there's kind of two areas
that are exciting to me around mobility.
One is, you mentioned there's lots
of different private companies
working individually.
And I'll go back to my public policy
and also my partnerships
kind of vision to say
there's an ecosystem that is yet
to be created,
where these systems
are working together and where it's not,
there's a place for the city
to be involved there
and kind of what's for the public good.
Right.
Not only individual companies
with individual riders,
but starting to look
at the city as a whole.
There's this whole concept
of the 15 minute city that
I think is really interesting
and really exciting.
What is the concept of 15 minute city?
I don't know that.
You can get anywhere in 15 minutes.
That's what makes a good city
according to this theory.
It means having
certain goods and services close to you
and it means
having accessible transportation
to get where you need to go.
I think it would be great
to get anywhere in 15 minutes.
I think this is one area
that we're going to see
more developments
that actually help people
in their lives.
And I think the second area is around,
and this is something
that's really exciting to me,
thinking about Nemodata,
is this area of artificial intelligence.
So, starting to see not only
how we have the operation side
of these mobility services
that are doing a good job today
of offering rides
or offering scooters
or whatever the case may be,
but then starting to have this
artificial intelligence is actually
optimizing things on a level beyond.
So, I think that's something
that's really exciting.
And there's a lot to be explored there.
Even before we talk about
what Nemodata actually does,
what is the problem
that you're describing here,
that you're saying on one hand,
we have the operations
and we're getting pretty good at them
and matching
and doing all the logistical stuff,
what is that layer that we're missing?
What do you think?
Yeah. Yeah.
So, I think that, and again,
it can be from everything,
from scooters to logistics,
but there's so much data
that's being generated,
so much data.
And I'm not talking about,
Michael wakes up here and goes here.
I'm not talking about this unique data.
I'm talking about aggregated,
kind of on a macro level.
There's so much data being generated
and it's almost like a tsunami
that then, you know, it takes
I think the next phase is to say,
okay, what data do we actually need
and how can we use it
to actually bring insights
that improve things.
I think when it comes
to artificial intelligence,
this is where artificial intelligence
can help us see through the noise
or cut through the noise
and come up with really smart,
actionable things to do
to actually take improvements.
It becomes beyond just
moving from point A to point B
as an individual and it becomes,
how do we optimize the whole system.
Right.
Kind of macro.
So, Nemodata is trying
to work on that problem.
But how do you do that?
How do you approach this new market
with this new understanding
that a bunch of this data also,
I mean, you're coming from
a world of partnerships,
you need to acquire the data
from these partners?
Sure. Sure.
So, Nemo is looking
at preventive maintenance.
So, preventing breakdowns for fleets
and before they actually happen.
So, we see a tremendous opportunity
both in terms of commercial vehicles,
like Class A trucks that break down.
They break down a lot
and it costs a lot
both in the expense of fixing it
and also the revenue that's being missed
when those trucks aren't working.
We see shifts to electric vehicles,
we see shifts to autonomous vehicles.
So, all these really interesting things
that are happening with fleets.
And then somebody's got to prevent them
from actually breaking down,
and make sure that those fleets
are actually running
and that they're on the road.
I don't know about you,
I wouldn't want to be
on an autonomous vehicle
that just stops working.
And there's no driver to tell me.
No, no.
There's no driver to
keep an eye on things.
It really needs to be
through artificial intelligence.
And also with electric vehicles,
nobody's run these vehicles
constantly 24 hours a day.
Commercial vehicles
have all kinds of stresses on them
that we don't know yet.
So, there's a huge place
for artificial intelligence to help us
take all the sensors,
pull the data in, compute it,
and come up with some
actionable insights there.
I think what you're saying is fascinating
because I've never even thought of this.
When I think of, you know,
moving to autonomous vehicles.
It's the eminent future
that is hopefully not too far away.
I'm thinking of myself being in a car,
and I'm not even worried
that the car will do an accident
because I trust the autonomous vehicle
more than I trust myself.
And I'm a pretty good driver
and I still trust the autonomous vehicle
much more than I trust myself.
But obviously, any machinery,
anything that is moving,
has moving pieces,
let alone electricity running through it,
is going to break down at some point.
So, even if that autonomous vehicle
breaks down once every five years.
Right?
That's still a scary thought.
And I would want something
to be able to tell me,
to tell the company operating it,
"By the way,
we think in the next few weeks,
you might want to check
on a few things here."
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
There's definitely a place
for artificial intelligence
to do the things
in the background that we,
as consumers or drivers take for granted.
From your perspective,
the vehicle should show up
and it should work.
And everything that has to do
with preventing issues
should be happening all around.
100%.
I'm guessing that until
these solutions come to place,
the obvious solution
is going to have to be regular checkups,
regular maintenances.
I believe that when I spoke to Gal,
from Nemodata, he shared with me
these astonishing facts
about truck breakdowns
across the United States.
And how much money
is being wasted
in daily, monthly, annually,
on truck breakdowns
that could be prevented
if you would just have those sensors
that are predicting
when it's going to happen.
Yeah. Yeah.
There's definitely major applications
for this today.
So, the figures we've seen are that
there's 85 billion dollars
wasted every year--
Unbelievable.
--just to use on truck breakdowns
that could be prevented,
both in, again,
those direct costs
and in lost revenue
from the vehicle not working.
Actually those same vehicles
are responsible for 5%
of the US greenhouse gas emissions,
which is an insane amount.
But it doesn't have to be that way.
You can also reduce the emissions
by keeping a vehicle in top form,
by changing the parts on time,
by making sure that the tires
have the right air pressure.
This kind of stuff
affects vehicle in crazy way.
100%.
Amy,
it's fascinating to talk about mobility,
but even more than that,
I love hearing your insights
along the way.
So, having gone through these experiences
and now I feel that I've gained
a little bit more insight
into the mobility space
and some of the thinking process
that you go through,
throughout the years.
But what are some things that
if you were to look back,
you were to tell your younger self,
even whether it's a point in Duke,
or at an MBA with Waze, or Moovit,
what things would you tell yourself?
Yeah. So, I think I've had definitely
a journey with myself
over the last 10 to15 years
of kind of coming into my own,
coming into myself as a leader.
I think that I,
I'm not usually the
oldest person in the room
and sometimes the only woman in the room.
I'm definitely not
the loudest one in the room.
And so, it took me a while
to start to understand that those
what makes me different
is actually my superpowers.
And that it's not weaknesses.
And to own that, I mean,
I think I remember so, so clearly
during my MBA,
I studied with Israelis.
When I was in this group of Israeli guys
who'd been in the military,
they have their kind of leadership style.
And I remember the teacher
gave us this assignment.
We had like 15 minutes to work on it.
And so, I read the assignment
and I said to everyone,
"Okay, what do you think?
What do you think?
And what's your input?"
And tried to kind of, keep us on time,
build consensus.
And we got to the end of the 15 minutes.
And then the teacher says,
"Okay. So, who's the leader to present?"
And I turn to the group and I said,
"Who's the leader?"
And they said to me,
"You're the leader."
And something went off in my mind.
Yeah, I'm the leader.
I'm not just the helper
or the facilitator,
or the supporter.
By engaging everyone,
by getting that consensus
and bringing everyone in,
I'm the leader.
And so, I went home that day and said,
"I'm the leader."
Amazing.
It was a journey for me
to understand my style
and learn how to use it
and learn how to use it as a superpower.
And what I love about the story is that,
while you're explaining
the environment that where you were
bring together the consensus,
you didn't even mention
if you even said your opinion.
And I think that's one
of the remarkable aspects of leadership.
It doesn't even necessarily to have
the person who speaks the loudest
or is the first to say their opinion,
but the person who is also able
to get the consensus
and hear everybody, and then,
adapt even their own views
after hearing everybody
and putting it all together.
I think that's just wonderful.
Amy, I can't believe 20 minutes
are almost up.
I really enjoyed this episode.
Thank you for being on the show.
Best of luck with Nemodata
and what you're doing there.
I think it's just phenomenal.
And I'm very hopeful
that by the time
that autonomous vehicles will be here,
when I'll be in the vehicle,
I'll know that it's being powered
by the preventive analysis of Nemodata.
But before we leave, Amy,
I need to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Sure.
So, I think calm,
calm under pressure.
That's definitely one.
Collaborative.
I love working with people,
bringing people together
and getting there,
getting where we're going together.
And curious.
I love learning new things.
And I try to approach
even the hardest, hardest things
with curiosity,
with kind of a question of
what is it going to feel like
when we do this amazing thing.
I'm sure it's pretty exciting
moving from a big company like Gett,
all of a sudden, to a small
early stage startup
that is just getting started properly
and being in that court team.
I'm sure it's incredible.
Never boring.
Amy, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
Best of luck - to Gal.
And I can't wait to see
powered by Nemodata
in all the vehicles.
Yeah. Yeah. Think of us. Bye.